[Music]
foreign so it's definitely time for
Republicans to put aside their personal
differences and come together why
because Democratic policies there what
is destroying the country take a look at
the chaos Biden's border crisis has
caused in fact the problem has gotten so
bad now it has spread to every single
corner of this country every city every
state new reports saying illegal
immigrants now are so overwhelming
hospitals in New York City they don't
have the resources to deal with it and
also sources telling Fox News illegal
immigrant border crossings yet hit
another new all-time high in September
what a shock there'll be eight million
illegal immigrants in three years thanks
to your President Joe Biden who's aiding
and abetting the law breaking here with
reaction Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator
how are you
Sean great to be with you thanks for
having me all right before I get to the
Border I want to ask you this I want the
pressure to move to your body and
meaning the financial pressure for
example your fellow Texan chip Roy got
together other Freedom caucus members
they put forward two CRS one that would
have cut spending by eight percent but
still funded DHS veterans and our uh
Department of Defense the second one
would have cut that spending by 30
percent and also included hr2 that's the
house border bill then it would have
gone to the Senate where you are and
it's there that I view people like you
and Senator Mike Lee and Marco Rubio and
Rand Paul you guys would fight for
fiscal responsibility in the Senate and
finally the pressure needs to be there
because that's where all these ominous
Omnibus bills usually end up coming out
of anyway don't they
yes and I think that would have been a
much better path for us to go down
listen as you know chip Roy was my very
first Chief of Staff when I was newly
elected to the Senate I'm really proud
of the job chip is doing I think he's
shown smart conservative leadership in
the house and I think if we'd pass the
CR the chip and other conservatives
championed it would be a much better
outcome than where we are today I got to
admit Sean and I was sitting here
listening to your monologue the
frustration you're expressing
I understand I think I'm feeling many of
the sentiments that Republicans and
conservatives across this country are
feeling on the one hand
the House of Representatives is the one
bright spot we've got we've got a
democratic radical left-wing
Administration that's doing enormous
damage we've got a Democrat Senate under
Chuck Schumer that's doing enormous
damage and the one glimmer of hope is a
republican house and and so sitting here
tonight I don't like seeing chaos I
don't like seeing a mess in in the lone
republican-elected body at the federal
level
I will say at the same time listen my
hope is coming out of this we unite I'm
going to stay out of leadership fights
in the house that's up for the for the
house members to decide but I do hope we
come together and say these crazy
Marxist radical leftists that are
destroying the country we are unified
against I don't know who the next
speaker of the house will be but I hope
they focus on something I called for a
year ago nearly a year ago which is we
should be impeaching Alejandro mayorkas
right now for absolute dereliction on
the southern border for creating the
worst illegal immigration crisis in our
nation's sister but but Senator he tells
us the border is closed and that it's
secure I mean are you not believing them
even though we'll have at the end of
three years at least eight million
illegal immigrants that they have
allowed to walk in without background or
health checks uh that now every American
city has to pay for every every person
at a time we can't afford it you mean
they're lying to us I'm shocked he is
flat out lying Kareem Jean-Pierre stands
at the White House Podium she flat out
lies every single day and she doesn't
just do so on her own she does so on
behalf of the president of the United
States Joe Biden is flat out lying
Kamala Harris's flat out lying and the
important thing to understand what
Alejandra mayorkas is doing it's not
just that he's bad at his job it's not
that he's lousy he doesn't know how to
do it he wants this crisis to happen he
looks at the 7.6 million people that
have crossed under Joe Biden and his
reaction is that is not enough he's not
trying to stop it he's not trying to
secure the Border he's trying to
accelerate it he views his job as he
wants even more people to come even
faster illegally to this country their
objective is to turn 7.6 million into 10
million to 12 million into 15 million
because they look at that every one of
them as future Democrat voters and they
do not give a damn about the dead bodies
that are piling up in my hope state of
Texas they don't care about the
thousands of children being brutalized
about the women being sexually assaulted
out of the about the over one hundred
thousand Americans dying of drug
overdoses so my hope is the next Speaker
of the House impeaches Alejandro
mayorcas then turns around and in
peaches Merrick Garland right after that
goes right after the politicization and
weaponization of the Department of
Justice and the FBI indicting Donald
Trump four times using the FBI to Target
the the administration's enemies I think
if we lead as conservatives that is a
unifying and winning message going
forward
I think that's great advice for
everybody any uh Senator I couldn't
agree with you more anyway we appreciate
you being with us thank you sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else